this is not a math problem this is a you
lied to me hid from me stole from our
family and think it's okay and it's not
freaking okay
Deo is with us in Maryland
hi Deo how are you good afternoon mr.
Ramsey how are you doing today better
than I deserve what's up um my husband
and I took um Financial Peace University
in November of 2017 through our church
prior to that we had a lot of financial
issues in our family and we were
separate with the way we managed
finances after the class during the
class we were encouraged to get rid of
our credit cards and he was completely
on board we cut up the credit cards we
paid everything off so far we started
out with debt of two hundred and thirty
thousand dollars of non mortgage debt we
were it we've been able to pay down to
one hundred and ten thousand dollar
where to go Wow thank you but we've had
also other family problems
just just marital issues that we're
dealing with and we're in counseling for
during one of our situation he expressed
to me voluntarily that he opened up one
of the credit cards which we had in my
mind was already gone and that he used a
portion of the credit card to consult
from the consultation from the lawyers
and that didn't make sense to me because
the amount of money that he told me he
spent for consultation and retained
retention fee for a lawyer was 2300 and
the situation that he was referring to
that made him go to a lawyer didn't seem
like it was something that he should
have done that so I went doing my own
investigation and found that he had
actually been using the credit card for
more than a year now for other purchases
just personal things that he was
that he needed IKEA Barnes and Noble and
things of that nature and just spent
$300 for a legal consultation which
didn't make sense to me but that's
exactly what I found out when I
confronted him with the information he
initially did not want to own up to it
wasn't outright an upfront about the
situation but my question now is how do
I we've been able to move past that
we've gone to counseling and we're
working through the marital issues and
he's promised me that he was going to
try to pay off the credit cards on his
own I don't have to worry about it it's
not part of our snowball and it's not my
issue but I just feel completely
betrayed because we had taken this class
and we had been doing a lot of it how
long ago did all this occur this
happened within a week about it about
about a week week ago right now yes but
I found out about the credit card yes
you found out about the credit card one
week ago
less than a week maybe about five days
ago and you've already met with your
counselor about this and already moved
on is what you said well regarding the
marital issues oh you've not discussed
the fact that he lied to you about a
credit card with your marriage counselor
no we haven't gotten there yet yeah you
need to
I think let me tell you what's happening
here okay you you're on unstable ground
you're walking across the pond on frozen
ice and it's cracking all around you and
you feel really scared because you don't
know what to trust because Trust has
been broken in several different areas
of this relationship am i right that is
correct yeah and this is yet one more
and so what we've found in our financial
coaching and working with marriage
counselors is that when someone lies
about something after we have a solid
marital contract meaning you all had you
know had a handshake agreement that
you'd gone to the class you weren't
using credit cards anymore and he
straight-up lied and
sieved and hid this from you that it
activates the same part of your emotions
that an affair does and so people in our
world are started calling it financial
infidelity because it makes you feel
kind of the same way right that's
exactly how I feel well somehow I'm
getting the feeling that he thinks it's
all about the money no it's not it's all
about it's all about lying and it's all
about trust the money is not an issue
you started with two hundred thirty
thousand you're down to two hundred and
ten thousand twenty three hundred
dollars is not a problem
right absolutely it is not about the
money this is not a math problem this is
a you lied to me hid from me stole from
our family and think it's okay and it's
not freaking okay and that that's what
you're feeling yeah
betrayed it's a trust has been broken
and so yeah this is something you guys
really need to unpack with your
counselor and I'm glad you've got one
you need one and continue to work this
through because he needs to grasp the
idea that lying to his wife is probably
not gonna work out well yes about
anything so I guess my question now is
do I do we proceed do we continue with
the bed yes assuming we can get back on
the page of trust but dude you know you
really have he's really he's really
asking to end his marriage if he keeps
his crap up because you probably only
got one or two with more of these things
in you and you're gonna be done you're
gonna you know cuz any normal sane human
being is not gonna put up with
somebody's looking you in the face and
lying to you all the time
so this guy y'all misbehaved you got all
these other issues all these things with
financial problems and everything else
you've worked it through you were on a
path towards healing and he decides to
you know sidebar here with this and you
start to wonder what else have you lied
to me about
and that's just normal human nature I
don't know if he lied to you about
something else or not but I mean this
dude I'm wondering if he's willing lied
to you about Barnes and Noble
my god that's a fairly low bar what's he
willing to lie about you know what if it
was something big that actually mattered
you know so yeah yeah I think this goes
to the counselor and I think you guys
work it through and no you're not being
crazy to have the feelings that you have
hopefully y'all can work them through I
hope you can I hope he stops this
misbehavior and I hope there's not other
misbehavior tied to this credit card but
that's that's what you're looking for is
you're trying to rebuild trust and
you're exactly right this is a trust
problem